welcome back to the real rejects I'm
Greg Alba and welcome back to the real
rejects I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch new rock stars with
Eric Ross yeah yeah this is what I've
been waiting for the second those Disney
Plus troves big game spot drop for
Falcon Winter Soldier Hwan division and
Loki I was like rock stars gonna put out
videos I don't gonna put out one for
Loki but definitely there's one here for
a Valentin at Winter Soldier that one
shot one shot my channel 25 minute
breakdown they have coming up if you
guys haven't subscribed new rock stars
yet you're gonna want to do so and
[Laughter]
[Music]
just like Captain America deserves to
[Music]
kick at the end of endgame alternate
history created by decision mr. penny
yes thank you but any games directors
they believe cap created a new branch
timeline
played out off screen back to this prime
time line it hit off the shield
screenwriters and others have suggested
actually loose is a rogue yeah that's my
cat with this random these yeah my
camera the reason I bring this up is the
directors alternate history explanation
we might still see something okay thank
God realize that it's more important for
Sam to carry a shield in the way and get
things in this universe the legacy of
Captain America speedy key theme of this
series with the government pony now a
doppelganger so perhaps a cat once the
worthiest soldier he can imagine
rallying the public to the truth and
that is better written counselor Sam
Wilson not globally we did assassin bug
barks yes Mandarin actually cats old
boot the backhand prison ik wing is he
that appears to be some kind of farm
home start surface parking spot notice
that once and bring the trees that
typically grows in the American South
Stark's farms in New York apartment
smarmy City Missouri some have suggested
that this farm looks similar to the
Rambo
with the rig it's got a rich wallet or a
technician but but go to these probably
that's why we're doing this video just
try to get that sponsorship back just
happen to have it on like this one
that's a lot of much longer a lifetime
warranty there's yours John's mine
Celeste
we have that bag to my favourite back I
don't think I got any of the rich items
I was very
oh the guy had an Avenger sign
here Russell Walker was introduced
America explain why he's being graded
here as this kind of Boy Scout poster
boy as Steve Rogers was as a PR tool
could work 30 40
I'm guessing this will create a conflict
between Wilson the successor cap shows
and Walker the successor Ross in the
government but by his ass that's not
America Harrod faustina get some sleep
buddy love Eric Voss but I hope he's
okay cuz he's just always breaking these
videos down you know sometimes those
theories go why why we're gonna say
another great new rock stars breakdown
video that shot at the at the football
stadium I couldn't tell if that was
actually a part of the show or if that
was just some image they threw in there
because this trailer was premiering at
the Superbowl time with this breakdown
moment I actually really appreciated it
clarifying that this is probably John
Walker a super Patriot looking at the
new Captain America logo but also the
thing they pointed out about how its
kind of reflecting what we saw in
Captain America the First Avenger how
they used Steve Rogers as a PR tool a
showman of sorts and how they're pretty
much doing the exact same thing here
it's making me kind of wonder why are
they doing that are they trying to hide
the fact that Captain America Steve
Rogers is no longer with us so they're
putting in a gute they're putting in a
dude who looks kind of similar to him at
least under the masthead of everything
they said here that moment of clarity
actually really appreciate it a lot or
maybe he's just a new football player or
it could be you know the government
introducing a new symbol of justice
their way you know because super Patriot
obviously doesn't share the same ideals
that Captain America doesn't so having
somebody under the thumb of the
government who they can control seems
like it might be a thing that they would
be inclined to do you know there was a
lot of talk that Aaron Voss was putting
here about how there's potential Envy
over the shield I don't think the show
is gonna go down that path I mean
there's there's quite a few reoccurring
things they were pointing out that this
could possibly be leaking too that
there's nothing here at least especially
we have endgame went down that would
hint at the possibility that Bucky would
be jealous at all or really want to take
up the Captain America shield and then
looking at Zemo and Bucky those scenes
while I get where he was coming from on
this to me at that moment actually
registers as a potential moment really
showcasing growth and evolution for
Bucky considering what happened in civil
war
Zemo completely mind controlled Bucky
and exploited him he used him that
moment to me at least of a brief little
second who he caught of it registered
more as he found him but he's not going
to kill him which is an old thing that
Bucky definitely would have done before
and this is showing no he's not going to
kill him I don't think like that's the
final scene like oh they've been hunting
him now and they finally caught him but
still Zemo i think will be an ultimate
Batio overarching the season perhaps
something to do with even super patriot
that's just more than impression that I
got potentially or or I can imagine
zimos being sort of a reluctant but
necessary part of their plan or some
reason they need to get in contact with
him maybe he's not the main bad guy
because I feel like a series like this
would want to have some new character
it's like yeah super pastry could be
that or somebody we haven't seen yet
yeah I could definitely see Zemo being
pulled in in some kind of dubious way
you know maybe they have leverage over
him or something maybe he escapes at
some point but it is cool to see him
back and to get at least at ease at some
wrap up to that history and yeah I don't
really feel like Falcon and Bucky would
really have a reason to fight over the
man
I feel like it just makes sense that
they would team up over it is you know
because they don't seem to have a heck
ton of friction in the past already and
I don't know it just seems like a petty
squabble for them or be the new Captain
America when like neither of them has
the Super Soldier Serum the same way the
calf does that's true
I mean I'll disagree that I think they
have major attention from the past
Captain America the Winter Soldier is
where Sam Wilson was first introduced
and a big part was helping to take down
Winter Soldier where we've come since
yeah perhaps best buddy he's got a know
by now them yeah it's a dude yeah I
still feel it we'll get the buddy cop
I'm glad they reminded me of the sokovia
accords thing cuz so much has happened
since Civil War you know with the blip
and everything I'm like oh yeah that's
the cobia course thing is probably still
in play there at least being discussed
likely as to that in a post blip world
yeah I feel like it especially since the
heroes taking charge was the thing that
reversed the blip baby yeah they're
essential so maybe there's an argument
there and they did point out how Zemo
last time we saw him was being held by
Martin Freeman's ever Ross so maybe
we'll get a Martin Freeman cameo in here
it's what I'm hoping for it's right it's
all I'm tuning in for you know what I
think we'll get a Captain America cameo
too it's gonna be that annoying handing
off thing that they do where Captain
America will appear in the first like
five minutes of the first episode and
then it's gonna make us go man I really
wish Captain America was here the entire
show but he's not going to be and then
he's gonna do he's gonna look at the
shield and then it's gonna zoom in then
we're gonna zoom on his face and he's
gonna go next time and he's gonna leave
yeah reboot happens but where's the farm
that's what I want to know where is it
is in Louisiana is it somewhere other
than that I think there's no validity at
all to the trees and trying to decipher
that it was all every banishment so much
of southern phenomenon America's so much
of filmmaking involves like taxes and a
whole bunch of weirdness we have to
shoot here for this purpose we have to
shoot here for that purpose how many
things take place in America that they
film in Canada
all the CW shows alright so I don't
think examining the type of trees it's
gonna really let us know whoa those
trees are specifically from that state's
great location title card comes up and
you see how wrong you are you're gonna
feel real embarrassed yeah but I do
believe that it could be a hideout for
both Bucky and Sam mm-hmm but man why is
he destroying trees you know like this
is not an environmentalist show
whatsoever man if that's the real
villainy is there tearing down the trees
this really is representation the
America that we live in where Swamp
Thing when you need them you see like
ray and rises Skywalker destroying trees
were part of our training Sam it's part
of his training destroying trees
what the hell stop destroying trees for
your training create targets go John
cough and dam and kickboxers come on
guys you know what to do stop destroying
environments Joaquin Phoenix is gonna do
a speech about it when he wins at the
Oscars all right guys what did you think
of this new rock stars video what do you
agree with Erik Voss about do you agree
more with us and the things we disagree
with Erik Voss about does that question
make sense which one of these shows are
you most excited for let's go with that
one guys subscribe to the new rock stars
channel because they are incredible
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell throw your shield our
way to get accepted in the reject nation
also it's time for up
Adelia chamberlain Adelia man what can I
say after everything that has been said
about you you are one of the people I'm
closest with at our patreon page
I love the living hell out of you I love
talking with you there's so much that
I've learned about you recently but
there's one thing I want to focus in on
right now your favorite food is Italian
food I did not know that
that's incredible than now
it's mind-blowing I'm half-italian I
suck at cooking Italian food though so I
feel like now we got more in common John
is a really good cook so if you were to
cook some Italian food let's say a deal
II and I wanted to hang out have some
dinner her and I friend date what would
you cook for us alright a deal yeah I'm
gonna make you guys both a homemade
pizza to start out with all right you
know maybe go off-roading on it put some
sausage little veggies maybe mix up the
sauce maybe make it like a white pizza
or pink pizza or something you know now
then you know I knew more starch I'm
gonna boil up some noodles I'm gonna
make you a nice of tomato sauce and then
I'm going to make a dish but I'm gonna
shape the spaghetti the pasta and the
sauce like the both of you guys holding
hands right so then you're not even
gonna want to eat it because you're
gonna be like this is art John made us
with his incredible mind-blowing talent
and skills for culinary as well as
visual media and you know then you guys
are going to starve but luckily you'll
have that pizza that I made you because
that's just gonna look like a pizza you
know and a little bottle of two buck
chuck from the Trader Joe's because you
can't get better than two dollar wine
love you Delia definitely listen to that
whole thing yeah to fall asleep